okay jelly it is first up
let's do it
team
black let's go for a sicilian
nick sapphire thank you for
gifting two subs
all right
let's go d5
uh why won't carlson
why would carlson not play well he he he
said he isn't going to play
for starters why not
he cited lack of motivation
i should pay a bit more attention here
all right so
as long as i'm in a position here to
meet
c4 with a queen check
um
i don't think i should be releasing this
tension
um
so i'm gonna put the knight here
and the reason i say if i because if i
don't have this follow-up check then i
start to get pushed around
there here
let's say that wasn't checked then this
knight gets kicked
okay so this one
this one here if i exchange queens and
then play 94
there is a convenient defense of both
f2 and c5
and i don't know if i'm guaranteed to
get that pawn back either
boom boom boom boom
if i play e6
there is b4
so
i think
i think i need to uh
i need to just take on c5
not too familiar with these lines
car kit could relate
car kite
suffers from lack of motivation
otherwise you'd be champ
i don't that's a good question pat
i don't i don't know
there does seem to be
a great number of players who are
playing the alpine maybe
maybe when you dive into my insights
is is that a piece of information
is there a glaring weakness with the
my my replies to the alpine sicilian
does it i don't think that shows up
though with the insights
all right where should the queen go
offer clean exchange
there
here
hmm
guess i'll go here
if i'm scared away
with b4 i have c2 c7 this seems like a
reliable square
so what can i say about this position
white has a majority on the queen side
does that mean it should get rolling
right now
not quite sure about that
probably need to get that light square
bishop out
and then get castled
i should be looking to do similar
kingside
i think it'd be
crazy for both of us to
castle queen side so
and right now i'm three moves three
tempe out from castle and kingside i
don't like that
much rather be a move or two away so um
i think i'm
certainly leaning
towards uh making a quick pawn move
maybe maybe now
could i however get away with deploying
this guy first yeah i don't know
yeah you see if i play this maybe
there's some irritating queen b3
maybe i i have to be content with
having my bishop inside the chain
uh
if i try to be a bit
more aggressive with my pawn going to e5
instead of e6 keeping this diagonal open
i'm
asking for some trouble maybe
this knight's gonna end up here here
i guess i'm gonna go one square
it's dangerous
i am on the night
it's gonna move though
where to
if knight here
well okay if knight here i go here
as far as i could tell it's the only
square
if the knight plays here
i think i want to cut off the
intersection between the queen and
knight on d6
with knight d5
hit the bishop
i don't want to let's say play this one
let the knight drop in here and then ha
try to try to cope with the queen on d6
she's
she would be an absolute monster so
i think i need to go ahead
and play knight d5 first
this there's the queen exchange rook d1
let's let's play this one first
i wanna i wanna try and get this knight
out of here if i can
my opponent is not listening to the
stream they're being a good guy i'm sure
right
we don't want any stream tactics you
could always listen back keep in mind
everyone has access to the vods
you know why i say that make my opponent
feel guilty in case they are
my opponent would never do such a thing
jelly is a is a good player they would
they would never try to be a sneak
artist
right jelly it
that's the thing with these rapid games
okay
lining up
sneakiness
uh how concerned do i have to be about
that one though
how concerned maybe i'll run home
and be a chicken
let me go with the chicken move
now
if c4
i could play here
we've played 10 moves but
i look at it for 10 moves to only have
two pieces out
it's a little off
no one would stream snipe me yeah well
maybe you haven't seen that video
how to trick us a stream sniper
maybe maybe it's okay if it happens
again
put out another stream sniper video
if i'm successful alright what do i want
to play here
that one that one give them a kick
none of the above
i think i could say
this night's under control
i could live with the
in my house for
for now
you're not bothering me enough to scare
you away
so
uh also in considering these two squares
i'm going to this
more conservative looking square at
least because i don't want to eventually
run into
expansion with tempo
i don't know that it would be played
right away but in eventually
i think
these moves are
a
a path forward for white
so these guys currently are
at a a bit of a standoff
if this guy's given a kick this guy's
probably going to move
shortly there shortly thereafter
um no i mean i should be going here i
think
let's see this
here maybe the knight goes there
maybe then i have e5
now that i have a little bit more
development in i could invest this
additional tempo to get this guy here
and then i have some nice squares for my
bishop
he needs to play
i don't know if i want to go about it
like this we'll see
okay some immediate pressure here i
don't want to allow my pawns to be split
so
should i initiate the capture
or
reinforce my knight on c6
with my bishop or maybe my queen even
um
i should hurry up that's what i should
do
my clock just turned red
get a move on it said
if i can i would i would prefer to keep
this structure as is
do without e5
chop here 95
maybe i go to east
e e8 okay
my knight needs to find a new square
and it probably should be on this
healthy f6
post hard to argue with a king knight
or any knight on f6 and f3
active
it's everything
active defensive
okay
keeping the structure as is follow move
knight e5
not knight d4
okay
i wonder if i have to part ways with my
light square bishop
do i have time to
or maybe i should play here and see if i
could be a provoker
yeah let me try this one let's let's try
to provoke
ff3
being sneaky
checaroni on d4
yeah this is the right way i think i
could abandon this diagonal okay so it's
it's simply challenged so
i don't think i want to take
wait a second i could take here though
that forces the knight to retreat
queen takes drops the bishop okay
so now
i think it's about equal
i think the queen does well to go to
where i don't know that i want to go
into an ending
um let's start with that one
i have
however slight it is i have
a little lead in development
will that translate into maybe the win
of some material
somehow i don't know about that
we both need flight squares
okay some defensive c4
should i improve my knight
think i want to improve my knight
yeah let's try that one
i'm assuming bishop e3
bishop e3 and then i was thinking a5 but
uh
i don't know
i think i may need to challenge that
pushup yeah let's go with this one i
don't want to see this move
and you know i don't want to not be able
to capture that
let's take here so now i'm looking at
this and then there
still think it's even
positional-ness
a knight on f4 could be dangerous
secure my knight
let's start with this
i don't know that it matters which rook
i usually prefer to go with the queen
rook in these cases
some in between move of rook takes on d8
isn't hitting with check
you go with the other rook it is hitting
with check
how big a role does that play i don't
know
i don't think i want to allow b4 c5 so
i'm gonna have to
prevent b4
and a little give and take
stopping b4 but now this is weakened
maybe i could work around it though
knight on b5 queen on f4
we still need flight squares
we're both under a minute
i've been living off of the increment
for some time now
i wouldn't mind a queen exchange
let's say queen e5 queen takes knight
takes f6 f5 king f7 king e6 are all nice
healthy improving moves
maybe even knight e6 into d4
oh
are going with the queen there
okay if if my queen was defended
or if i make any queen move this is a
threat then fork
but let me let me go back to what i was
pointing out queen takes and then f6
yeah so my king has an easier time
being a contributor
in this ending
so i think i'm now slightly better
maybe
maybe beginning to be
a bit more than slightly better
um yeah let's let's go here right now
this cuts out the maneuver into b5 the
knight's now under control by my pawns
alone
if it goes backwards it's also negated
well with my knight on c5
rook here i'm prepared to exchange
support my knight and then look to hunt
what i think will be
a liability
a white pawn on d5
if it becomes isolated i think it could
be tracked down
both at 25
i'm not thinking uh
much beyond okay well hang on for a
second
could i look to double rooks now
or what if i play this right now
i don't know that i'm getting anywhere
let me begin with improving the king
this should be a guaranteed productive
move
it has to contribute
okay
have things changed any after that move
96 here
or do i continue improving the king i'm
going to say continue improving the king
i don't know if the
moving any of my pieces are
or being helpful let me expand on the
the uh king side
okay you're ready for a knight here but
now there isn't knight f3
so let me let me plant this rook here
now
right here take take take take okay
okay maybe i could be a
annoying very soon i think i'm
threatening some stuff now
knight d3 knight f4 knight d3 knight b2
possibly
some softening up move
h4 h3 if h4 is stopped with h3 then
there's a big weakness on g3
okay that one
i could exchange both rooks i don't know
how that i want to do that though
no i think this is a winning move
because this hits the rook and now next
up there's this check
and i'm ready to
exchange rooks and then take here i
think i should be winning now
yeah check you know after this move the
only one to save the rook
i could take a pawn with check
i have at minimum a perpetual check
i should definitely take this one as a
start
now i'm looking for
a clean way to convert this ending now
that i'm up a pawn
how do i approach it
i think improving the night first
is a good idea
exchange both rooks
start to move some pawns
yeah let me let me let me
move some pawns i like my knight right
where it's at i'm not seeing
what else to do i want to
just get rolling with these pawns it is
it is a fort four to two
if rook takes rook i'll be taking with
the rook
no i i don't care that this guy becomes
past i want to i want to keep them
compact i want to keep them together
still as an island okay let me revisit
some checks now
i don't know that the checks are really
accomplishing so much let me negate the
forward move by the night
so no good forward moves if this
knight's under control this rook
isn't felt
oh we've got a new square for the pawn
but i have a check and then here
now let's go for that one
grab another pawn
a4
this i'm not ready to do this because my
rook would hang but after this i would
take twice and then take here
there was a thread here anyhow
this is a
defensive move
and and attacking move
okay yeah the rook should be the
recapture
this this this this
this
i got too many pawns
still up to
that night is not within checking
distance i should take there take this
pawn first
and then i guess go hunting for another
one
with rook b4
is there better
i don't think so
it's gonna rook b4
i should be getting a third
third pawn soon
could take with the knight or the rook
but i prefer the rook
welcoming more exchanges and not putting
myself in a pin although
this capture does
does come with a threat to
give check and win the rook so let me
consider this the night's a long way off
from
scaring my king
here
how do you stop this one or this one
yeah i think it's
i think it is quite alright
to take with the knight
if it's a rook specific end game
i'm okay if this pawn drops
oh i was ready to play here
yeah i forgot that there's
knight takes rook
all right they resigned good game and
jillian let's have a look at it
let's see
computer analysis
is running
okay let's see if there were any misses
in the early stage because it did
eventually get to a point where it was
super duper positional
what's the best what's the most popular
move most popular just by a little bit
is a queen exchange 98 games to 95.
okay i went with queen takes pawn
the graph there's the graph
tight game
right into the end no that's not
complete
there's the graph i don't know what that
first one was
even steven
until
the queen exchange yeah
that's where i felt it started to pull
my way a little bit i
pointed out the my king
is gonna have an easier time
assisting in the end game
so
maybe that's even the
first
thing to speak of because i think it was
pretty decent game here
what if c4 instead knights knight f6 it
seems right around equal
i trust the i trust the
engine bishop b4 instinctually i was
looking at this keep the knight under
control but bishop e4 is good
i don't know what to say
is even game
if i didn't play a5 if i flick flick in
this move b4 is there
it's not amazing for white but these
guys start rolling so
a5
yeah and something else something other
than the queen exchange
maybe a flight square what is it
suggesting g3 knight d4 into b5
yeah g3
uh
has a couple of things in mind the main
one of course is the
flight square but you also knock out
a potential pivot by the queen on f4
or even a knight though it's a
ways away from getting there right now
okay once the queens were off it
still i slowly gained some ground there
i guess it's i guess it's easy to go
wrong it's suggesting knight b3
knight b3 b6
this construction is nice
to
it's tough to get in a past pawn with
this grip over b4
you need the assistance of some other
piece to get this one in without losing
upon
have a nice pivot here
a little pull
for black
okay
good game
you